[Music]
we're here for your online activities
that you've been doing its first message
dear I'm 11 she stated her age
straightaway he scaled the child abuse
is happening that was likened to an
illness it would be a national emergency
do you know what damage it can cause a
child this joking no it's not sorry it's
just some father double how many people
are out there doing this
I was arrested for sitting with somebody
y'all realize that there are thousands
of those
our overall impression is that activist
groups are not helpful to the policing
effort for a range of risk
the cottage cheese yeah we're not
interested in that
[Music]
on the road to Birmingham in the car up
ahead
a team of pedophile hunters which is on
routes to meet the other guys we're
going to be meeting cold and then we'll
be meeting via and Stacy four separate
teams from the Midlands and north of
England have joined forces to track down
a man they suspect of trying to meet
underage girls he's he's a slow groom I
think he's done it before he's been
about done it quite a few times before
in terms of this language and what he's
talking about I feel is quite dangerous
individual especially with the amount of
children that you're speaking to and the
fact that he's not organized to meet or
some pictures to every single one it's
only two one
pedophile hunting groups are often
heavily criticized for being little more
than lawless vigilantes but these
hunters are determined to show us their
evolving more responsible than other
groups
accused of driving some suspected sex
offenders to suicide yeah we've got
seven decoys on this person he is
confirm his location in the country the
ages are ranging from 11 to 14 for
several weeks Kong not his real name and
jaw have been gathering evidence on the
man they intend to confront tonight I've
got the videos we've got the
conversations they're all pretty much
the same then we're talking about please
delete the conversations age isn't an
issue for him at all several of the
hunter colleagues have posed as underage
girls in Internet chat rooms recording
many hours of conversations which they
claim proves their target is a pedophile
what we've seen through the chat logs on
going into them is a repeat of pattern
with each individual child decoy he's
speaking so his pattern is the same in
each he's trying to establish trust he's
establishing a pattern of grooming with
a look to go to a conversation of a
sexual nature with the child it's very
very obvious that he is actively seeking
I'm an underage child very knowingly
speaking to a 13 year old about you
could even touch me on top of my jeans
while we were sitting side by side of
the cinema he goes on to suggest that he
can some pictures of himself to the
child of his manhood and also tells them
that they have to delete it straight
away after which is showing that he's
being cautious and he's fully aware that
that doing that is wrong
the man the hunters are after is out
drinking at a Birmingham city centre pub
so okay pictures have just handed out
our images of the male and the correct
current image of him what he's believed
to be looking like at this moment we've
verified that through a video call so
his own son this male that we're going
to see tonight as they prepare to
confront him the man is still chatting
online to one of the hunter decoys who's
posing as a 13 year old girl he has no
idea what's coming
good as the hunters head off to confront
this man we're just going to hanging
back a bit we've seen before how people
can react very badly to the shock of
these confrontations
a few minutes later the hunters have
persuaded the pub security to escort the
man out the back door where they're
waiting
[Music]
we're here for your online activities
that you've been doing
that's first message dear I'm 11 she
stated her age straight away
[Music]
these hunters say they abide by a proper
code of conduct taking into account the
well-being of their target but listening
to their interaction with this man it's
pretty forthright do you know what
damage it can cause a child this joking
it's not sorry you can damage these
children for the rest of their lives the
car tears yeah we're not interested
[Music]
the activities of pedophile hunting
groups pose a real dilemma for the
authorities their evidence has helped
convict many but some groups seem more
concerned by the shock and awe of
confronting suspected offenders than
gathering evidence for a successful
prosecution
for sexual purposes right a growing
number of these confrontations are
ending in tragedy you're not a pedophile
should I put it to you are this is Nigel
Sherratt confronted by a group of
activists who claim he thought he was
about to meet an underage girl in the
pub what are you welcome in the pub it
makes for difficult viewing and all the
more traumatic for those being
confronted as these videos are posted
online listen to me Nigel I'm not
mediate I'm not a [ __ ] listen don't
treat me as any deals I'm not a vidiots
within days of this confrontation the 47
year old took his own life he had not
been convicted of any offence and his
family insist he was innocent
there are teams out there that don't
work in an ideal way I don't agree with
swearing and shouting and belittling
that person but I know that that's a
standard for some teams the man
responsible for helping set police
national policy around pedophile hunting
groups is clear for the most part the
negatives outweigh the positives there
are occasions when when activist groups
have carried out operations
investigations and handed material over
to the police and that has resulted in
dangerous pedophiles being locked up and
sentenced to custodial sentences however
our overall impression is that activist
groups are not helpful to the
effort for a range of reasons the
operations that we've seen them carry
out have resulted in in people with
mental health issues
young young offenders who have got
learning difficulties being targeted
people who aren't actually pedophiles
that's one of our concerns another
concern is that the sophistication of
some of these activist groups is really
really low and it's obvious that they
are carrying out their operations so
they're not targeting the more
sophisticated offenders the authorities
may have no choice but to take pedophile
hunting groups more seriously several
have now banded together to create their
own national federation bound by a set
of common rules and training with the
aim they hope of working more closely
with law enforcement regardless they see
the scale of online grooming means
they're not going away thing for
technology is allowed offenders to be
instantly in the bedrooms with children
and it's growing every day more and more
people again devices each day more and
more people are seeking out sexual
gratification it's rare to hear
first-time from someone cornered by
pedophile hunters but Michael convicted
of arranging to meet an underage boy is
extremely bitter caught in a trap but
guilty he says our very little machine
to an offense which I feel like I'm
actually committed I wasn't actually
talking to a 15 year old I was giving
her suspended
sixteen years is just the worst ugly the
worst punishment I received other than
the fact it was made public and more
certainly the vigilantes highlight the
issue and how problematic online sexual
grooming of children is but the problem
is that they don't ever actually think
about the children what they're doing is
thinking about themselves hence videoing
pens putting it on social media about
what they've done rather than the
possibility of an online sex offender
being identified but should an
individual who's not trained just sit at
home pretending to be a child so they
can identify online sex offenders the
antis that is no they shouldn't
it's scary it is scary as a pedophile
hunter Bradley has not stopped around a
dozen successful prosecutions I was
regularly getting a hundred different
men message me a day easily but his
approach is different to the majority of
Hunter groups he doesn't engage in
confronting suspected offenders but
instead passes on the evidence he
gathers directly to the police there's
two types of hunters if you like there's
those that are trying to work with the
place and get convictions and do what
good work and there's the other set you
know if they do good work what they do
is good but they do let themselves down
by doing live stings it's unlikely many
groups will follow Bradley's approach as
they believe these on-camera
confrontations are a vital part of the
deterrent factor and however
uncomfortable the police may be they do
regularly use the evidence collected by
these groups the Birmingham suspect now
in custody cases the likelihood of
prosecution secured by the actions of
pedophile hunters
I'd see it as a proactive way of
intervening and catching offenders
before they hungry or children
I haven't physically laid my hands on
anyone and yet I'm on the sixth friends
of Richard for 10 years when I haven't
actually touched anyone I would be more
satisfied if the people that are
involved in in activism in this way
spent their their effort in other ways
then that would be more helpful to
policing my determination is to carry
this forward that you create a force
that has never been needed before but
it's clearly needed in our digital age
you